I probably have spent upward over 200
maybe 300 thousand dollars in just
medical it is expensive just to try to
be yourself
Claire's among an estimated one point
four million transgender people living
in the u.s. where even patients with
health insurance can face six-figure
bills there are surgeries like top and
bottom which can cost over $50,000 each
hair removal which costs hundreds of
dollars a month and a slew of other
expenses that most Americans never have
to think about let's really dig into it
so like let's talk about surgical
binders that you might need coming out
of surgery let's talk about other
prosthetics let's talk about clothing
that is comfortable it's time off yeah
it's so many expenses that work the
reality is that being trans comes with
all kinds of costs
[Music]
if you're trans your gender identity
doesn't match your gender recorded at
birth and this can lead to a form of
emotional pain commonly called gender
dysphoria it feels like you're trapped
in the flesh prison just extreme
discomfort almost self-hatred for
decades doctors tried to alleviate
dysphoria through counseling but it was
an abysmal failure
we have suicide attempt rates of 40%
among transgender people and so we know
that that's a failed strategy and that
left doctors with two strategies
changing the brain to match the rest of
the body or changing the body to match
the brain and when you think about it it
becomes pretty clear that the mucking
around in your brain is gonna be the
more invasive thing so people like
Garnett Lex Clare and Emmett opted for
strategy to changing their bodies to
match their brains this process is
complicated long and sometimes painful
but for many trans people it works being
a transition literally saved my life
my worst day me now as transitioning is
better than my best day I ever had in my
old life when I presented mail I'm able
to walk out this door and just be able
to exist without fear without compromise
but that doesn't mean everyone can
afford these procedures and it becomes
this to the point where you can drown in
debt from it how much you pay for health
care largely comes down to insurance
whether you have it and what it covers
an estimated 14% of trans folks are
uninsured and for them a single gender
affirming surgery like vaginoplasty can
cost over $50,000
but even if you do have insurance you
might still have to pay for care
out-of-pocket that's partly because some
insurance plans simply don't cover trans
related surgeries even though that's
illegal and virtually all cases under
anti-discrimination laws but there's
another reason and it's that many
insurers don't consider certain
procedures like facial feminization or
breast augmentation quote medically
necessary they call them cosmetic
instead and cosmetic tends to be code
for out-of-pocket which is partly why
people like Claire and appending to
empty their savings they just came down
with a hard no it is cosmetic that was
in 2019 when Claire tried to get
insurance to cover a schedule of breast
augmentation which now means that if I
want to get that procedure which I feel
I need just so I can feel more confident
with myself and just be able to stand in
the mirror and look at myself now I'm
gonna have to pay out of pocket for that
procedure and the procedure ranges
anywhere between twelve thousand
eighteen thousand dollars and Claire
she's just one of many in one survey 55
percent of trans people reported being
denied coverage for gender affirming
surgeries and that has consequences that
extend beyond financial and emotional
stress let's just say for example facial
feminization surgery for a transgender
woman that might be a very necessary
surgery of a significant point for that
individual is to be able to walk down
the street and be treated appropriately
according to her gender identity then
having a feminine face is going to be
enormous both for how she's treated and
frankly for safety and even if insurance
does cover your procedures there are
plenty of other expenses that most
people never have to think about if
you're a trans man for example you could
invest hundreds of dollars in binders
let's talk about binders right it's this
thing that you put on so that you can
bind your chest and so that your chest
is not so visible so for a lot of trans
masculine identified folk or trans men
it's super important to like not have
your chest visible also it's like a
matter of safety because I could be well
into my transition
and I still have my chest that can you
know sort of like out me
each binder could cost like $40 and then
there are packers prosthetic penises
which can cost hundreds of dollars each
you know sis guys don't have to pay for
their penises right it comes with the
package you know whether you like how it
looks or not trans women on the other
hand have a different list of expenses
so the most expensive thing for a trans
woman is hair removal especially if you
do electrolysis
it's about $75 to $100 per session just
for your face I mean you can be doing
this for anywhere between three to seven
years yep just to get a reduction and
then there's something that both trans
men and women have to buy because my
body changed so much when I started
hormones like I grew out of my clothes
so I had to basically buy a whole new
wardrobe so that's just it even without
medical procedures trans people might
spend thousands of dollars just to be
themselves and unfortunately many of
them don't have that kind of money to
spend the unemployment rate in the trans
community is about three times higher
than the national average plus nearly a
third of all trans people including Lexx
report being homeless at some point in
their lives and the Trump administration
may be making these issues worse in 2017
Trump announced a ban on trans troops
serving in the military which is of
course a form of employment and in 2019
the administration wrote new rules that
will make it easier for health care
providers to deny treatment for trans
people if it violates the religious or
moral beliefs but that's not to say the
u.s. hasn't made any progress in 2002
for example zero percent of Fortune 500
companies offered trans inclusive health
care coverage while today nearly
two-thirds of them do and a number of
states like New Hampshire have enacted
various pro-trans laws but no matter how
the US continues to change for better or
worse there's at least one thing that
seems to always stay the same and that's
the unshakeable resilience of the trans
community trans people are beautiful
trans people are resilient
we've existed for a long time we're
gonna keep on existing that's what we do
so this was awesome
[Music]